bonjour les gens non vous ne rêvez pas
je suis bien en pyjama parce qu il est 6
heures du matin alors pourquoi est ce
que je fais une vidéo à ses heures du
matin et bien tout simplement parce que
les voisins d'à côté là donc le mur qui
est juste derrière le mien ils font des
travaux toute la journée donc c'est
impossible de tourner une vidéo avec des
bruits de perceuses de meuleuse
donc allez on va faire ça comme ça je me
suis maquillée à larache un fast and
furious on sauve les meubles histoire de
pas faire peur aux abonnés bon trêve de
bavardage on a vu les fils à cannes a
donc maintenant on va voir la deuxième
partie à savoir les katakana mais aussi
les secrets pour apprendre efficacement
attention il y aura une petite annonce à
la fin de la vidéo donc rester bien
jusqu'au bout donc sur son père pas plus
de temps c'est parti générique
[Musique]
à quoi servent les katakana
principalement ceux pour écrire les mots
d'origine étrangère il ya beaucoup de
mots anglais qui se sont glissées dans
la langue pam piotta qui veut dire comme
qt ou la mène oui le ramène est
d'origine chinoise donc c'est tabou
étrangers c'est pour ça qu'on l'écrit en
kata kata les noms des villes et des
pays étrangers par exemple la france
prenne ce pari ali
nouh prénom par exemple anaïs anaïs pied
l'eau piot on s'en sert également pour
écrire les onomatopées notamment dans
les mangas tout ce qui est bruitages
mais également lorsqu'on veut faire
ressortir un mot dans un texte c'est un
peu l'équivalent quand on écrit en
caractères gras ou quand on utilise des
majuscules par exemple quand un
personnage cris dans un manga on va
l'écrire en katakana très souvent
examinons un petit peu le tableau des
katakana comme vous pouvez le constater
dans le tableau des fils à gannat et
dans le tableau des katakana on retrouve
exactement les mêmes syllabes ce sont
les mêmes sons mais ils sont écrits
différemment alors dans la première
rangée on a à y eu et au puy cas qui que
keko sa chute ce zoo
thaçi ce taux
n'a ni ne n'ai non
ap guy fouquet coupe
m'a mis me mets mots il ya lieu liot la
bi 2b do
wah wah
vous avez peut-être remarqué mais les
katakana sont plus anguleux alors que
les flagada ont des formes plus
arrondies cran
on va commencer par les katakana qui
ressemble au chat ghana ce sera plus
simple en premier on a le fait il n'y a
aucune difficulté c'est exactement le
même pour le où on a bien le petit trait
au dessus sauf qu'il est vertical et
qu'il est collé au reste le cas en
dehors du fait qu'ils mentent le petite
raie sur le côté il est relativement
similaire qui il manque juste la courbe
du bas le haut est identique
s'est il n'y a pas de deuxième barre
verticale et la ligne horizontale c'est
un petit crochet au bo tôt mais il
ressemble un peu à un taux sauf qu'il
est plus anguleux mon attention la ligne
verticale ne dépasse pas et elle ne
rebute pas à la fin
ja il manque le petit trait et la barre
oblique n'est pas arrondi
dit bon bah c'est à peu près kifkif pas
de grosse différence
voilà vous connaissez déjà neuf cas pas
cas là c'est plutôt pas mal maintenant
on passe à la suite
pour le haj et trois types à vous
proposer le premier c'est que ça
ressemble un peu à un a penché si on
retourne un petit peu le katakana
sinon quand vous allez chez le médecin
vous savez au moment où ils vous mais
cet horrible bâton dans la bouche et que
vous avez envie de vomir et quand il
vous dit faites à en tirant la langue
bien c'est exactement ça donc vous
imaginez un personnage de profil vous
avez sa bouche qui est grande ouverte et
laslandes qui pendouille ça fait à eau
alors on peut penser à un arbre donc là
on a le tronc mais c'est un arbre un
petit peu particulier parce que son
feuillage est juste sur le côté c'est ce
qui fait cette partie là donc ça fait à
[Musique]
et alors ça ressemble un lit c'est juste
qu'au lieu d'avoir un point on a cette
barre un peu haut blick un peu comme
s'il avait un chapeau pencher comme ça
sur lui là vous pouvez aussi penser au
chapeau de l'accent circonflexe
ou alors vous pouvez imaginer tout
simplement que vous avez écrit le i avec
un pinceau et de langues mais que l'anc
a la bave et du coup ça fait cette trace
comme ça et donc ça vous donne plus
[Musique]
le où on l'a vu précédemment
et alors là je pense à une étagère donc
on a bien les deux niveaux de l'état
gère et au milieu on a les livres ça
fait le son est
[Musique]
haut alors moi je vois un chanteur
d'opéra donc opéra est un chanteur qui
fait eau
il se tient debout
il a les bras ouverts et sur le côté on
a le bout de sa queue de pie qui part à
gauche donc pensez bien à aux deux
opéras
[Musique]
cahill est similaire au chellah ghana
donc vous pouvez toujours pensé au
katana la seule différence c'est qu'il
n'y a pas la petite goutte de sang
[Musique]
si c'est la même chose donc penser à qui
les clés en anglais
[Musique]
coup alors malheureusement pour celui là
je n'ai pas d'astuce à vous proposer
mais rassurez vous il y aura des petites
solutions après j'expliquerai ça un
petit peu plus tard
qu'est alors on peut voir la lettre k
si on penche un petit peu le katakana on
voit la lettre k le cas de quai hors cac
en anglais ça se dit qu'est donc ça
donne key
[Musique]
coc je pense un coffre vous voyez bien
la forme du coffre mais c'est un coffre
qui a deux sangles de coin et là je
pense à conner en anglais coin les
angles donc c'est un coffre avec deux
corners ça fait qu
[Musique]
pour ça il y a trois méthodes on peut
penser à la bonbonne de sacs et dont on
a la forme de la bonbonne comme ça et le
dessus le couvercle ça fait ça
sinon on peut penser à 3
sardines ça fait toujours ça et enfin on
peut penser également à la coiffe du
samouraï donc vous voyez bien il ya
cette ligne ici et là il ya ces deux
trucs là voilà donc on peut penser à
samouraï choisissez celle qui vous
convient le mieux
[Musique]
shi il ressent clairement à smile et
donc on a bien les deux petits yeux et
la bouche alors pour le distinguer il ya
un petit mémo technique qui est que il
épouse la forme du chili en fit la ghana
ce je pense à un ninja vous savez les
ninjas qui courent ils courent toujours
les bras en arrière comme ça d'ailleurs
je n'ai jamais compris comment on
pouvait courir de cette façon ce n'est
absolument pas ergonomique ni
aérodynamique enfin moi je me vient d'un
conte je fais ça clairement parce que
mon centre de gravité il bascule à
l'avant bon les ninjas eux il y arrive
apparemment je pense que les japonais
c'est une race à part donc vous imaginez
votre petit ninja qui court comme ça les
bras en arrière et il va super vite non
le ninja qui courent super vite
[Musique]
sait on en a déjà parlé il est très
similaire au ghana c'est
[Musique]
non alors c'est un petit peu comme le
chi sauf que il lui manque hanoi 10
donc là on peut penser à un pirate
puisqu'il a son cash money comme ça donc
il ne lui reste qu'un oeil qui peut
utiliser et en fait il regarde en bas en
fait ils regardent vers le sud en
anglais sens donc penser aux pirates et
à sauf ça fait sow
[Musique]
le pas alors là on peut imaginer une
hache qui sert à taper ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta donc ça fait le sont pas
[Musique]
si on peut penser aux antennes
paraboliques des années 80 qui sont très
chip pour vous avez bien cette forme-là
qui ressemble à une vieille antenne non
il n'y avait pas la fibre à cette époque
là
[Musique]
ce alors là c'est un piège parce qu'il
est très similaire aussi la différence
c'est que pour le chi les yeux sont
quasiment horizontaux alors que le tss
les yeux sont quasiment verticaux
l'autre moyen de le reconnaître c'est
que comme pour le chic qui ressemble au
fil à gannat chi le tss aussi peut
s'inscrire dans la forme du sud vous
avez bien les deux yeux en eau et le
sourire qui épouse la forme de la vague
donc penser aux qui la gagnent à ce
[Musique]
t alors là je pense aux poteaux
électriques vous savez ce qui relie les
lignes téléphoniques
donc on a effectivement la barre du
dessus la barre du dessous et le poteau
donc le thé pour téléphone
pour comme on l'a dit il ressemble quand
même pas mal aux pieds la haganah tôt et
sinon vous pouvez également penser un
toute haine dont vous avez la ligne
verticale donc c'est le totem principal
mais sur la droite il y a un bras qui
dépasse notamment les ailes de l'aigle
donc vous avez le chirag anatot vous
pouvez vous servir de totem
[Musique]
n'a donc je pense un narval vous savez
cette espèce de dauphins hibri qui
ressemble à une licorne d'ailleurs je
pense que c'est une chimère le normal
donc vous avez le narval
excepté mena gens là comme ça et en os
vous avez bien s'accorder ça fait le son
nom
[Musique]
ni alors c'est assez rare pour être
souligné mais c'est grâce à un qu'angie
que j'arrive à m'en souvenir tout
simplement parce que le camp jean nice
écrit exactement de la même façon ce
sont deux lignes horizontales pour la
petite info le chiffre 1 ça se dit ichi
ça s'écrit avec une barre le chiffre 2
ça se dit ni ça s'écrit avec deux barres
et enfin san le chiffre 3 ça s'écrit
avec trois bars une deux trois voilà
maintenant vous connaissez 3 qu'angie
ces cadeaux
[Musique]
ne alors ne il ressemble très clairement
au numéro 7 si vous regardez bien on a
bien la forme du set donc penser aux
nues mais recettes et si vous voulez
renforcer la mémorisation vous pouvez
même imaginer que le 7 il est tout nu
oui à oilpé donc vous pensez au numéro 7
tout nu ça fait ne
[Musique]
mais alors là malheureusement non plus
je n'ai rien à vous proposez moi je lui
ai appris tel quel vous pouvez tout à
fait trouver votre propre nos mots
techniques d'ailleurs rien ne vous
oblige à utiliser les tips que je donne
c'est juste là à titre indicatif mais si
vous avez une idée qui vous parle plus
une image qui vous parle plus utilisé là
[Musique]
non
ah désolé j'ai une extinction de voix
non alors non c'est le plus simple il
n'y a qu'un seul trait alors là on peut
penser à la signalisation vous savez le
petit panneau qui dit no smoking donc on
a bien cette espèce de lille là qui
vient barrer la cigarette le no smoking
donc vous pouvez penser à ça pour lenovo
ou alors on peut penser au nez en
anglais n'ose donc là vous pouvez penser
un personnage qui est un très long et
donc imaginer celui que vous voulez en
tout cas celui qui vous impact le plus
soit ça peut être cyrano de bergerac
ça peut être ou soap aussi ça marche
très bien
donc vous avez le long nez donc ça fait
le no no 11
[Musique]
a alors là je pense aux à deux pattes
chapeau donc là imaginé cette espèce de
chapeau lachinois là vous savez en forme
de cône donc vous avez bien le a
[Musique]
si on peut voir le visage de profil
d'une personne qui sourit la première
ligne qui descend et qui fait un arrondi
ça fait le menton et s'inclinent là
c'est le sourire donc c'est la bouche
qui sourit ça fait fit
[Musique]
feu alors là je n'ai rien en plus de
particuliers à vous proposer pour ce
canal
[Musique]
et on l'a vu c'est exactement le même
que le chili ghana donc vous pensez au
saut de chez je le rappelle il faut
prononcer le rachat
[Musique]
au g2 astuces à vous proposer donc soit
vous pensez à une croix chrétienne en
anglais holy cross le cros de rauly
ou alors vous pouvez penser à un homard
donc un homard donc vous avez bien ces
deux pinces
s'est pas tu
es en haut vous avez bien sa queue et au
milieu le corps ça fait trop
[Musique]
ma je pense sa maman donc là il faut
visualiser une maman qui tient son petit
équivalent à l'été donc on la voit de
profil il y à cet angle là qui fait la
ligne de sa poitrine donc à la dépouille
énorme qui pointe un c'est très pointu
comme vous pouvez le voir donc imaginer
le moment bien plantureuse mais avec des
piétons pointu
et la ligne en dessous c'est l'angle du
bras qui porte le bébé donc ça vous fait
bien leçon m'a
[Musique]
mis alors vous pouvez choisir entre deux
méthodes soit vous pensez à trois
missiles trois missiles ça fait me mets
à mon écran qui bouge ou alors vous
pouvez penser aux griffes d'un chat ça
fait trois griffes salle a donc pensé à
un chat très vénère très en colère qui
vous a griffé le visage en criant fini
donc le mythe de mia ça fait nous
[Musique]
jme alors nous je trouve qu'il ressemble
vraiment au chiffre quatre jeux pas pour
vous mais moi en tout cas ça me fait
penser à ça donc ma petite astuce est de
penser à quatre murs donc 4 le chiffre 4
et murs vous avez bien le son mais donc
quatre murs a fait le son me
mais je pense un célèbre personnage
d'animer un personnage qui a une jolie
cicatrices vous voyez de qui je parle
c'est zorro évidemment avec kenshin ça
marche aussi un donc pensez bien à la
cicatrice du personnage d'annie mais ça
fait le sont mes
[Musique]
mots on l'a vu il ressemble au chai la
gare un mot non vous pouvez toujours
penser à la momie sauf que cette momie
elle a été un petit peu abîmés entre
temps on lui a décapité la tête donc il
n'ya pas de petits traits qui dépasse ya
juste les bras et pareil elle a été
amputé du pied du coup ça ne rebute pas
au bout ça vous fait mots
[Musique]
il ya il est très similaire au chellah
ghana donc vous pouvez toujours pensé
oiac mais attention le yak aussi a subi
une petite amputation il eut donc sa
deuxième cornes donc vous avez sa tête
sa corne et son coût mais n'oubliez pas
il n'ya pas le deuxième titre et ça fait
hier
[Musique]
ue
je n'ai rien à vous proposer grand plus
pour riou désolé
[Musique]
you on peut imaginer un petit bonhomme
qui fait du yoga donc
ça va être très difficile de le mime et
parce que moi je ne sais pas de yoga
mais vous pouvez imaginer la première
ligne c'est sa tête qui est en voie là
moi je peux pas le faire sinon je vais
me péter les cervicales
la ligne ici c'est son dos la deuxième
ligne horizontale ce sont ses bras et la
dernière ligne horizontale ce sont ses
jambes vos places vous ne me voyez pas
évidemment mes jambes sont sous le
bureau ça fait le son you
[Musique]
là je pense à ma mère donc ramène en bon
français donc au dessus vous avez cette
ligne horizontale ce sont les baguettes
et en dessous c'est la forme du bol ça
fait pas
[Musique]
me bats ras un cycle est quasiment
similaire au fil à gannat vous avez
toujours les deux petits bâtons pourquoi
toujours pensé aux de rin 2e ni ou aux
limaces c'est pareil ça fonctionne
[Musique]
2 alors moi je pense à une route ou à
une rue les deux fonctionnent mais on
peut même penser à une autoroute
pourquoi la première ligne c'est la rue
principale le et ici la deuxième c'est
la sortie d'autoroute la petite
bifurcation donc dans tous les cas vous
avez lu de rue hulu de route ça donne 2
[Musique]
mai alors cette petite forme là je
trouve que ça ressemble à la petite
patte plier d'un t-rex donc vous pensez
or et de t-rex donc ça fait les
[Musique]
l'eau c'est très simple je visualise la
tête carrée d'un robot robot low
[Musique]
oit alors je ne sais pas si vous le
visualiser mais je trouve que ça
ressemble un point d'interrogation comme
quand on dit what
le wpt à 2 watts fait watts
oh je pense à un chien qui aboie en
faisant maintenant
donc on va imaginer un chien avec une
énorme bouche grande ouverte et il ya sa
langue qui dépasse je sais pas si vous
le visualiser il est de profil il à sa
grande bouche et salons ça fait ou on
[Musique]
est enfin alors là on va repenser à
notre pirate le borgne de tout à l'heure
sauf que cette fois ci au lieu de
regarder au sud il regarde au nord donc
le n de north a fait
ça vous donne le sont
[Musique]
comme vous avez pu le constater certains
katakana se ressemblent beaucoup ce sont
des pièges regardez bien dans le tableau
[Musique]
pour shi et de se penser bien à leur
fils à gannat respectifs donc le chi
et de ceux pour sow et penser à sud et
nord
saussez sauf senor billon deux élèves
alors le il est en deux traits qu'est ce
qui me permet de me souvenir de ces deux
très bas tout simplement parce que je
pense à la rue ou à la route notamment
la sortie d'autoroute dans les deux cas
routes et rues ça fait le son le est
donc cette sortie ça fait cette
bifurcation là ça fait le deuxième très
donc par élimination l'autre c'est
forcément
coelho alors là aussi procéder par
élimination donc pensé ocana qui vous a
le plus marqué dans mon cas je retiens
plus facilement la tête carrée du robot
donc je pense à l'eau donc en toute
logique on en déduit que l'autre c'est
copé ya et a alors il ya une
ressemblance dagana donc il est penché
et le a il est droit notamment si vous
pensez au tronc de l'arbre l'arbre il
est droit
cook & key alors ce qui me permet de
reconnaître le son cas c'est que la
ligne horizontale elle est plus longue
et elle dépasse en fait par rapport à la
ligne verticale alors que le son coût
qui forme quasiment un bloc c'est comme
ça d'ailleurs que je me souviens du son
coup parce que je sais que s'il ne
dépasse pas ça ne peut pas être quai et
donc forcément ça ne peut être que comme
s'ils étaient alors c'est vrai que moi
je me souviens plus facilement du chip
chip donc par déduction l'autre c'est
forcément
tu as haineux alors ta il a une petite
ligne oblique qu'il n'ya pas sur le
noeud et penser au fait que ta ne
ressemble pas au numéro 7 donc forcément
ne sait le set l'autre c'est le thym
ou et oies alors pensez bien que le ours
embauché lagana donc il ya forcément le
petit bâton au dessus sur le voit il n'y
en a pas
là et feu alors sur le las il y à la
ligne horizontale pourquoi parce que ce
sont les baguettes du ramène qu'on ne
peut pas avoir donc fou et enfin ou o
efoulou donc là c'est pareil pensez bien
aux chiens qui aboient donc lui il a
forcément sa langue qui sort c'est ce
qui fait la deuxième ligne il n'y a pas
cette deuxième ligne dans faut donc s'y
lie à cette ligne au milieu c'est
forcément le son ou
comme je les dis n'hésitez pas à trouver
vos propres démos techniques notamment
pour les cannas pour lesquelles je n'ai
rien pu vous proposer sinon il y à une
solution c'est la formation objectif
japon je mets le lien en barre d'infos
grâce à cette formation vous allez avoir
beaucoup d'astuces pour apprendre vos
cana mais également vos qu'angie il ya
exactement le même genre d'astuce
visuelle des petites histoires qu'elle
raconte pour pouvoir mémoriser les
kanjis alors moi les cannas je les
connaissais déjà mais ça m'a quand même
fait une très bonne révision et pour les
kanjis ça m'a carrément sauvé la vie
voilà donc sachez que cette formation
peut être prise en charge par votre cpf
donc si vous avez un compte cpf vous
pouvez l'utiliser pour cette formation
donc
je dis ça je dis rien
[Musique]
on en a terminé avec le tableau
principal maintenant on va passer aux
autres sont la bonne nouvelle c'est que
ça fonctionne exactement de la même
façon que pour les six lagana donc si
vous avez déjà compris la logique ça va
aller tout seul on a toujours les
antennes et les mâts le
cas devient gars qui devient guy coup
devient go qui devient gay co devient go
ça devient à chis devient dit ce devient
ec2 vient des sceaux devient un
tas de viande à thé devient des taux
devient d'eau
ensuite on a ha bah pas si bibi que buzz
peu et bp aux bobos
idem pour le petit ya le petit houx et
le p'tiot
tia tio tio
via you bio
chat ce show dia dieu joe
mien mieux nyon
mia miu miu
l'ia bio bio
pia pia pia
ku bio bio
bio bio bio
pour doubler un sens on utilise aussi le
petit ceux par exemple 5 de weeds ti
sento et ti
et enfin les allongements alors là on ne
peut pas faire plus simple il suffit
juste de mettre une ligne horizontale
juste après le son qu'on veut allonger
par exemple
games en tant
qu'amis nda
[Musique]
alors comment fixer les cannas dans
votre mémoire déjà entraîné vous allez
lire et à les écrire il faut vraiment
les utiliser les mots sont plus concret
qu'un tableau par exemple c'est comme ça
que j'ai retenu les katakana qui forment
le mot phalène ce la france c'est à
force de chat avec des japonais donc
quand je me présentais je disais je
viens de france donc ça c'est un truc
que je disais souvent donc forcément au
bout d'un moment je savais l'écrire je
savais les reconnaître amusez-vous
également à écrire votre prénom en
katakana pourquoi déjà parce que
effectivement vous allez souvent
utilisée notamment pour vous présenter
mais aussi parce que le prénom c'est ce
qui vous est propre ça vous appartient
comme c'est quelque chose de très
personnel votre cerveau va vraiment
l'enregistrer et d'ailleurs vous pouvez
faire le même exercice avec les prénoms
de vos proches vos parents vos frères et
soeurs vos amis votre conjoint vos
enfants ce que vous voulez ce sont des
prénoms qui vous touche
concerne donc vous allez les mémoriser
également pour ce qui est de la lecture
il existe des applications pour pouvoir
lire des textes en japonais ayen je
mettrai les liens en barre d'infos il
n'est pas important de comprendre la
signification du texte et même s'il ya
des kanjis vous vous inquiétez pas c'est
pas important repérez juste ou sont les
gilles haganah où sont les katakana et
retrouver leur prononciation
autre exercice intéressant et qui
quittent holly testo donc les tests des
côtes alors j'en ai proposé un an cette
vidéo c'est donc vous pouvez l'utiliser
pour pouvoir vous entraîner et dans une
prochaine vidéo j'en mettrais un autre
donc n'hésitez pas c'est cadeau
bon vous connaissez vos kana vous
connaissez les petites histoires qui
vont avec vous savez les lire vous savez
les écrire
et un jour vous les oublier
pourquoi
il peut faire
on va aborder ce qu'on appelle la courbe
de l'oubli sachez que ce que vous
apprenez aujourd'hui vous allez
l'oublier dans sept jours
c'est ce qu'on appelle la courbe de
l'oubli si vous regardez le petit schéma
au jour 1 vous retenez à peu près 80%
des informations et/ou jours/7 vous ne
vous souvenez plus que de 15 % le
résultat est sans appel en fait notre
cerveau ne retient que les choses qui
voit régulièrement si ce n'est tous les
jours le rêve c'est pas utile dont
elle est ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut
faire des cannas à longueur de journée
tous les jours sans s'arrêter non
bourriner ne sert à rien pour être
efficace il faut être méthodique et il y
a des moments stratégiques pour réviser
pour économiser du temps et de l'énergie
il suffit de connaître les moments où
votre cerveau est sur le point d'oublier
une information et c'est à ce moment là
qu'il faut le lui rappeler en fait vous
fait une piqûre de rappel au moment où
votre cerveau est sur le point d'oublier
l'information c'est là que vous allez
imprimés l'information dans votre
mémoire à long terme
concrètement figra examinons ce petit
graphique fait votre première révision
dix minutes après avoir appris quelque
chose faite la deuxième révision un jour
après la troisième au bout d'une semaine
la quatrième au bout d'un mois et la
dernière dans six mois ça ce sont les
principales mais on peut en rajouter par
exemple dix minutes une heure un jour
deux jours une semaine deux semaines un
mois deux mois trois mois six mois sans
fait 10 à partir de 6 mois c'est gravé
dans le marbre ok ils révisent cola
c'est quoi la bataille j'y arrive la
méthode que je vais vous donner
fonctionne pour absolument tous les
canale qu'angie le vocabulaire les
formules mathématiques les textes de loi
si vous faites du droit ça fonctionne
vraiment pour tous je n'ai vraiment plus
devoir
pour cela vous allez utiliser des flash
cards alors qu'est ce que c'est c'est
tout simplement un petit bout de papier
sur lequel vous allez écrire au recto le
canard et au verso la prononciation en
alphabet romain donc les rom a dit
ensuite vous allez mélanger tout ça vous
allez piocher dans votre paquet de
cartes vous allez s'il ya une carte si
c'est la face kana vous allez prononcer
le canal et si c'est la face au magic
vous allez écrire le canna
attention lorsque vous prononcez leucan
a fait le à haute voix et pas uniquement
dans votre tête c'est très important
d'exercer les muscles de votre bouche il
faut vous entraîner à prononcer et à
prononcer correctement n'oubliez pas
qu'une langue ça se parle
on
retient beaucoup mieux lorsqu'on utilise
plusieurs sens la vue je vois le canna
louis j'entends quand je lis le canal le
toucher j'écris le cana il est vrai que
certaines personnes ont une mémoire qui
est plutôt visuel donc ils retiennent
plus ce qu'il voit d'autres ont une
mémoire auditive donc ils retiennent ce
qu'ils entendent et d'autre ils ont ce
qu'on appelle la mémoire de la main ils
retiennent quand ils écrivent donc en
fait si vous combinez tout ceci vous
multipliez vos chances de retenir parce
qu'en fait avec trois sens vous
mémorisées trois fois voilà pourquoi je
vous recommande d'utiliser et la
prononciation et l'écriture en même
temps plus vous allez combiner les
méthodes et plus vous à utiliser vos
sens en même temps plus vous allez
mémorisées si vous apprenez du
vocabulaire c'est exactement la même
chose vous utilisez une flash cards donc
au verso vous allez mettre la définition
du mot et au recto vous allez mettre
soit le mot soit vous allez mettre
l'image du mot
l'image est mieux j'explique pourtant un
le cerveau m ce qui est concret or une
image c'est beaucoup plus concret qu'une
série de lettres par exemple ça c'est
plus concret que ça on est d'accord de
la même façon ça c'est plus concret que
ça vient d'eux le cerveau aime la
couleur ce n'est pas pour rien que la
signalisation routière est fait à base
de couleurs par exemple un seul
tricolore est beaucoup plus impactants
visuellement qu'un panneau écrit stop
je vais vous donner un exemple concret
j'avais du mal à retenir deux mots le
mot violet et le
chauffeur doigt d'honneur c'est pas cool
donc le mot violet ou lhasa qui est le
mot qui lowy jaune pour mona s'acquitte
en fait moula
ça veut dire village et ça c'est un mot
que je connaissais et que j'arrivais à
mémoriser donc ce que j'ai fait c'est
que sur ma flash cards en fait j'ai
utilisé cette image donc un village
violet donc c'est très simple puisque je
retiens le momu là le reste ça venait
assez logiquement après où l'aca qui
pour jaune même méthode qui ça peut
vouloir dire arbres et îlots ça veut
dire couleurs très simple j'ai fait un
arbre avec un feuillage jaune donc à
chaque fois que je voyais cette image là
c'était très simple je pensais qu'il aux
jaune et donc utiliser des couleurs
c'est très important
troisièmement le temps que vous fassiez
vos cartes écrit rechercher les images
etc vous êtes déjà en train de mémoriser
parce que vous êtes actif donc vous avez
tout intérêt à faire vos cartes vous
même et choisissez vraiment des images
qui vous parle avouent des trucs qui
vous impact personnellement tu veux
vraiment s'imprimer dans la cabeza au
calme et moi je sais pas dessiner qui en
plus ça commence à faire beaucoup de
papier au bout d'un moment où est ce que
je vais stocker tout ça et en plus c'est
relou mehmedi mais la langue sur mon
téléphone pour réviser au bon moment
c'est papin mon petit boudin tu sera
ravie de savoir qu'il existe une
solution et cette solution s'appelle
hannequin qu'est-ce que en qui
oncle il est une application qui vous
permet de créer autant de cartes que
vous voulez et elles seront stockées
dans une espèce de cloud donc pas d
espace de stockage ni physique ni
virtuel vous les garder sur votre
téléphone donc où que vous alliez ou que
vous voyagez vous avez vos cartes avec
vous vous pouvez également ranger vos
cartes dans des paquets différents ça
vous évitera de les mélanger par exemple
cana qu'angie vocabulaire verbe
particules forme de politesse etc et
enfin gros bonus vous n'avez pas besoin
de mettre un timer pour calculer à quel
moment vous devez révisée en qui s'en
charge pour vous par exemple si vous
trouvez la bonne réponse tout de suite
ou très facilement vous allez cliquer
sur facile ou correct à ce moment là on
qui va considérer que ces acquis et il
va programmer la prochaine révision dans
un jour par contre si vous avez eu du
mal à trouver la réponse ou si vous ne
l'avez pas trouvé vous allez cliquer sur
difficile ou à recommencer et à ce
moment-là ans qui va programmer la
prochaine révision dans 10 minutes voire
moins
autres fonctionnalités très utiles les
enregistrements audio et oui vous pouvez
enregistrer vos cartes en audio alors ça
c'est génial justement si vous voulez
travailler la prononciation et
l'écoutent et comme je le disais tout à
l'heure vous pouvez combiner plusieurs
méthodes sur vos flash cadre donc par
exemple l'image plus le son ou le mot
plus le son ou alors le combo ultime
vous mettez l'image le son le texte là
où vous avez toute optimisation maximale
garantie si vous avez besoin d aide pour
utiliser l'application en ti ou si vous
ne savez pas trop comment vous en servir
n'hésitez pas à me le dire en
commentaire et je vous donnerai des
explications comment j'ai appris tout ça
pas tout seul notamment grâce à la
formation étudiant brillant donc on
apprend à étudier efficacement comment
optimiser son temps comment utiliser son
énergie pour apprendre un maximum de
choses en un minimum de temps sans faire
d'avc par exemple il ya des moments dans
la journée ou le cerveau est très actif
donc c'est à ce moment là qu'il faut
étudier al'inverse il ya des moments
dans la journée ou le cerveau est
totalement endormie pour ça il faut
éviter
on apprend aussi la technique du pobo
d'euros la lecture rapide faire des my
maps et séraphin bref je vais mettre le
lien en barre d'infos également donc si
ça vous intéresse de réussir vos études
jeter un petit coup d'oeil
voilà cette vidéo est à présent terminée
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu si tel est
le cas n'oubliez pas de lire et de
commenter et de partager
pensez également à vous abonner et
active et la petite cloche de cette
façon vous ne raterez pas les prochaines
vidéos vous pouvez également vous
abonner un brio type sur youtube vous
recevrez également toutes les
notifications et vous aurez accès à
toutes les fiches récapitulatives des
kanaks on a vu dans les deux dernières
vidéos sur youtube vous pouvez également
soutenir mon travail grâce à des dons
donc que j'utiliserai pour investir dans
du matériel de meilleure qualité
[Musique]
avant de vous quitter breaking news
avait dit que j'avais une petite annonce
à faire c'est officiel je pars au japon
le 2 juin
je suis dans le rush du départ je ne
sais toujours pas où est ce que je vais
habiter je dois trouver un travail bref
ça va être drôle hein comme d'habitude
j'en parlerai très certainement sur
instagram donc n'hésitez pas à me suivre
sur instagram vous aurez les news en
temps réel du coup je ne sais pas si
j'aurai le temps de sortir une nouvelle
vidéo avant mon départ je vais faire de
mon mieux mais sincèrement je ne
garantis rien donc si vous ne voyez pas
pendant une semaine pas de souci je n'ai
pas disparu de la circulation c'est
juste que je suis en train de recherche
comme une grosse part et pour essayer de
faire ma valise et tout le reste je
ferai évidemment des vidéos de ce voyage
donc le japon mon école pendant tout un
d'ailleurs s'il ya des sujets qui vous
intéressent en particulier et dont vous
voulez que je parle des choses que vous
voulez que je filme dites le moi en
commentaire et je l'inclus ray dans les
prochaines vidéos sur ce bisou les gens
et je vous dis à très bientôt dans un
nouveau fuseau horaire
[Musique]
où
tu peux tu as deviennent tu as devient
au
pourquoi je vais pas le dire alors là
c'est j'arrive plus article bay on le
met notés aaa à rebours août dans cette
non
ça ce sont les princes un tas de voix et
ça se sent non ça va pas mieux